getting ready to talk to the player of
the game here on the Inside the NBA
presented by KIA Devin Booker 32 points
seven assists four rebounds and that man
joins us now Devin Booker
congratulations on the win you got left
go here Inside the NBA I'm curious man
you got to play with Bradley Beal
tonight how was it I was exciting man um
you know just seeing his progress and
you know see him wearing that he wasn't
playing for you know however much time
he was out you know he he had good
energy today and he was excited to get
back out there but Jamal Crawford good
to see you out there again my guy my
question is when you were on the
sideline you watching Katie and you were
just watching him what were you picking
up that you're able to apply now that
he's out like how are you using your
teammates how you getting your shots it
seems to me that you have the perfect
balance between scoring and setting
those guys up and then taking over when
you need
to uh yeah I mean that's a tough balance
that you know I knew I was going to have
to take on that Challenge from the the
beginning of the year um people saying
that we don't have a point guard um I
mean we have scorers and we have
Playmakers around here so you know give
it to brag give it the KD and you know
let teams do their junk defenses and you
know operate after
that I have a question for you book this
VC here question how excited are you for
the opportunity for your big three to
play together you guys have not had the
opportunity yet but how excited are you
guys looking for all three of you guys
to finally get that opportunity to play
together man I'm looking forward to it
um you know I think everybody here in
Phoenix is too um the thing is when two
of us are playing you know teams still
throw those junk defenses because we
stagger minutes but you know if we are
always have two out there or three at
the most like you know it's going to be
tough on other people but you know
whenever that day happens I think it's
going to happen soon you know it's going
to be a good
time hey Dev Booker Grant Hill here
congratulations uh just continuing with
that thought what do you see as has the
potential of this team when you're all
healthy you guys are all playing uh to
your
capabilities what is the what is the
ultimate potential of this ball
club uh I mean we don't know yet um I
mean we only played a half and that was
in preseason you know at Detroit the
first first preseason game of the year
so you know I think you know there's no
ceiling for us you know obviously we
know the talent there it's just figuring
out the little things and the details
and The Chemistry Between all of us you
know not just all three of us making
sure the other guys are in the right
spots too so you know we know how
talented we are but you know it's going
to be the little things and the details
that matter when it comes to playoffs
dein Booker the team is now 13 and 10
man congratulations thanks for joining
us appreciate it all right so